explaining death loop simply as two
assassins stuck in a time loop manages
to both answer and ask
a lot of questions at the same time have
no fear because i got to see death loop
in action recently and i've got the
answers
here's everything you need to know about
arcane's latest
for more make sure to like this video
and subscribe okay
one of the two assassins is cult and the
other is juliana
colt is trapped on a mysterious island
and tasked with killing eight targets to
break the time loop that he's trapped in
you can play as juliana online invading
other people's games
so that you can keep the loop going if
you fear your chances against a real
opponent you can opt for juliana to be
ai controlled
colt and juliana are the cat and mouse
chase at the core of the game but
there's a lot more history to their
relationship than colt can remember
and that unfurls throughout it's
reminiscent of hades a roguelike that
would tell its story upon repeated loops
the conversations between the two never
repeat either because both colt and
juliana are aware of the time loop
unlike the other inhabitants of the
island of black reef
when you're playing as cult sometimes
juliana will radio you to comment on a
kill that you've just made
or if you've maybe run away from a fight
she'll radio you just to call you a
coward
this time loop takes place across one
in-game day but if you're worrying that
you'll be rushing against a timer to get
everything done
have no fear you can tackle everything
at your own pace
death also doesn't even mean the end of
a loop one of the powers we saw in
action gave you three redos per loop
so if you died you could return to the
encounter find and collect things from
your body and try again
if you die a third time though that loop
is finished
you also won't be starting completely
from scratch each time you start a new
loop
there's a resource in the game called
residium that helps you hang on to your
powers and weapons across
loops so not only will you restart with
an arsenal you'll also have more of
death loop's most important resource
knowledge the game takes place on a
mysterious island called black grief and
is inhabited by your eight targets and a
band of cult-like followers called
eternalists the island is split into
four districts
and each district can be visited at one
of four times during the day
and they change significantly throughout
the course of the day you might be able
to unlock a shortcut only at night or
maybe a visionary will pass through but
only at a certain time
according to game director dinga bakaba
the game starts by introducing you to
each district
then moving you to another until you've
visited all four
then you can choose which to go to and
at what time of day
once you decide to leave time moves on
when you get to the next one
if you go to a specific district at a
specific time to do a puzzle or maybe
follow a certain subquest and fail it
you can just leap right back into that
area and time period to try again
in a way death loop lets you make lots
of mini loops you don't just have to
keep doing the big one
if that makes sense by visiting these
locations over and over you not only get
the lay of the land and obtain
key items like keys and door codes but
you can build a plan
to take out your targets as efficiently
as possible like all of arcane's games
the setting
and the world tell a lot of the story
the island of black reef is an alternate
reality
loosely based on a 1960s aesthetic art
director sebastian mitos said that they
settled on that era because of the
carefree nature people had at the time
despite the anxieties of the cold war
people wanted to party forever
and so that filtered throughout the game
informing the look of the gadgets and
weapons as well as the music
the visionaries who live on the island
are a group of artists and scientists
who just want to live forever one
mission we saw was reminiscent
of dishonored's excellent lady boyle's
last party
in it you're tasked with killing lady
boyle at her own masked ball
but the problem is everyone is wearing
masks and her sisters are there too
in death loop one of the visionaries is
called alexis who you've seen in
trailers
as the one wearing a wolf mask similarly
you need to uncover his identity before
you can attempt to take him out
not every visionary encounter is going
to be like that but they will move
around and there are multiple ways you
can take them out
and boy are there ways to take them out
there are obviously
many types of guns to use because you're
an assassin interestingly though there's
no money in death loop ammo machines
distribute bullets freely because
if you're at a never-ending party utopia
why would you need
money if like me you loved the powers
from dishonored then you'll have plenty
to play with here
some may look familiar shift is similar
to blink or far reach
carnesis is similar to wind blast and
nexus works
in a very similar way to domino from
dishonored 2.
i mentioned reprise earlier which gives
you these extra redos but there's also
ether which makes you invisible
now seriously arcane where was that one
in dishonored
these powers use mana but you can use
trinkets to increase your maximum amount
trinkets are slottable items that can
also give you little perks like
dealing more damage or a cool double
jump if you play dishonored and you're
familiar with bone charms it's something
similar
when you kill an enemy whether by power
gun or simply kicking them off a ledge
their body doesn't lie around just
waiting to give you away
it kind of disintegrates so while i'm
not sure just yet if there's going to be
an incentive to do a clean hands or
ghost run like in dishonored
i wouldn't be surprised when it comes to
multiplayer it's woven into the campaign
arcane's approach to designing it is
that they want to incentivize creative
play
and hopefully the mode will be seen as
something of an anecdote generator
according to dinga
as juliana you can invade random games
or your friends and the game gives you a
list of feats to accomplish doing so
gives you points which you can then use
to unlock
new powers trinkets or weapons these
unlock randomly so you'll get different
loadouts every time you play
by playing the multiplayer component you
can unlock new appearances for cult and
juliana
so the incentivization there is
obviously the costumes you'll unlock and
the high scores but arcane genuinely
seem very excited to just see the clips
and
hear the stories of how players are
gonna be interacting online
one final thing to note about death loop
is that it is genuinely very very
funny so typically in arcane games the
humor would come from all of these
gameplay systems interacting
whereas in death loop they have made a
real effort to have the voiced
characters be really
genuinely quite funny i'm really looking
forward to it
i don't like watching you die i like
killing you
there's a difference
so to sum up defloop is some parts a
natural evolution of past arcane games
and something else altogether
it's a ps5 exclusive for a while and
we'll have more on it throughout the
year so make sure to like this video and
subscribe check out tomorrow's preview
on gamespot.com for more from dinger and
sebastian
and we'll catch you in the next loop bye
you